last time out against seattle was
absolutely brilliant 19 times he threw
something that they swung and missed
that's a rare performance and he had the
velocity he had the location and he did
just about everything right so against
the indians he's five and five his era
is pretty good last time out he threw a
lot of four seamers and got a lot of
ride especially up and into the right
handers the slider was very good didn't
use a change up for curveball very much
because he didn't have to carlos rodon
to jordan luplow who is just dynamic
against left-handed pitchers and that's
why he's in the lineup
he lofts it to left and rodon gets it
out to andrew
jose ramirez he's all for his last 14.
popped it up back of the plate
collins
will make the catch while don
goes one two three in the first inning
zach police gonna make the start for the
indians making his third of the year
please sack his first two starts as i
mentioned coming against the tigers the
last one was a gem uh he was two and uh
excuse me one and one last year against
uh
1-0 last year in three starts against
chicago 20 and two thirds innings 12
hits and 25 strikeouts
so already
mounting a bigger threat in the very
first inning than they did in nine
against bieber last night so they're at
the corners with one out and here comes
mankato yohan bashes this ball up the
middle that was a guillotine shot and it
drives in the sock's first run tonight
for a one-nothing lead
and that's exactly what we're talking
about monkana aggressive early in the
count gets a fastball to his liking
takes it right back up the middle and
it's one and upping socks this ball
drifts right over the middle of the
plate hits the glove of police act by
the way police is a very good defender
he is outstanding with the glove but
this one was hit so hard that he could
barely get it up in time he's trying to
defend himself but not before it goes
into center field yeah mean mercedes the
chance to hang a crooked number here in
the first still only one out mercedes
a galactical three-run home run
he unloaded again
that is a three-run bomb
and it's four nothing
and he did indeed light it up
fireworks are going off here at the
ballpark
it's like disco demolition night here
tonight
as the lights are flickering off and on
as the white sox jumped to their
four-nothing lead here in the bomber the
first pleisack has just not been able to
get comfortable so it's four-nothing
vaughn just doubled
and here's laori garcia
first pitch hunting garcia to right
field at the wall and it's over the head
of naylor
sax will get another run laurie garcia's
got a nickel for the sox in the first
inning
indians bullpen is getting ready as
quickly as they possibly can and on a
cold night that's not easy but zack
kleesack is getting hammered here in the
first you're wondering where the offense
is it's right here and it's magical the
number nine hitters so eaton who let it
off with a single is now on deck the 0-1
this one ripped out into the alleyway
right center for a base hit garcia's
going to score
madrigal will be held to a long single
and they are pouring it on six to
nothing yeah he's gonna go get him
absolutely two-thirds of an inning now
for zach
he does not survive the first chicago
six cleveland nothing white sox with
runners at the corners two down here in
the third and phil maton the third
pitcher used by the indians robert out
into deep left
in the corner it's gonna get down and
bounce out of play hit the warning track
and bounded into the bullpen
so garcia will be allowed to score
madrigal however will be set back to
third that is a run scoring double and
it's seven to nothing
it would have been eight nothing robert
will have to take seven nothing and the
bases are loaded for moncada
that got him it grazed him on the way by
and an rbi
for moncada it's eight nothing it
catches just
a piece of his wrist
maybe a little of a hand and he
drives in another run carlos rodon's got
an eight-nothing lead he has not allowed
a base runner through three faces jordan
luplow to lead off the cleveland fourth
he struck him out oh and a primal scream
from carlos
well he came back and he got a very good
hitter you fall down 3-0 and you come
back and record your first strikeout of
the night that's getting it done carlos
rodon to friend neil reyes eight nothing
socks roll fair to the third baseman
mankata long throw good stretch by abreu
for the out 13 in a row retired and
fortunately jawan was hugging the line
that's 13 in a row retired by carlos
rodon to open play tonight ahmed rosario
swinging a ground ball right to the
shortstop garcia the throw to first got
him carlos throw down perfect through
five and he's got a big cushion
carlos rodon has been through
shoulder trouble arm trouble
this is his 100th career major league
baseball appearance and it has been
special so far tonight no base runners
for cleveland
with one out in the sixth
hit it hard to short stop leo garcia
out number two how long will we remember
that play
that's up to carlos the rest of the way
he made that look easy that's not an
easy play here's chang with two outs
call strike three
he rings him up on a slider
perfect through six
this is getting interesting
does not get any easier jose ramirez and
he's got an offer that he's trying to
snap line shot to left right at one he's
got it
perfect through seven
brand neil reyes the d8 against carlos
rodon
[Applause]
reyes skyward
and playable
madrigal
got out number one
five to go
this is jake bowers he busted him on a
fast ball in the attic
four to go
his passion for the game comes through
the jersey
and his body wouldn't let him do it for
the last two seasons but he's been nails
so far tonight
ahmed rosario the shortstop
swinging in a miss strike three
perfect
through eight
if you're not nervous you don't have a
pulse carlos rodon against josh naylor
tapper first base side afraid who is on
it jose got to the bag well done
they're gonna look at this as long as
they want to in real time he was out and
when they look at it he's still gonna be
out and he's out
and two to go
one down in the ninth perez all for two
he very easily could be two for two
inside perez
he got hit by it perez got clipped by
the slider
wow
what a way
to end the perfect game bid it actually
got him off the top of the foot my
goodness
carlos is talking to him
he said really can't you
can't to fake this one
carlos rodon will not be perfect tonight
but the no hitter is still available and
the batter is
yucheng called strike three on the
inside corner or in the neighborhood
and one out for a no-hitter
tommy john surgery
shoulder trouble
seven games in 2019
four last year and now he faces a menace
to
has
lefties
a no-hitter
after everything he's been through
the elbow and the shoulder
were supreme
on april 14th
2021.
[Applause]